alcohol is one of the most popular  drinks all across the world but it  increases the chance of cardiovascular  disease and cardiovascular disease is  the world's number one killer  long-standing view suggests that  moderate drinking is good for health but  too much alcohol is bad for health but  this particular view is challenged by a  recent research published by the  researchers at mit and harvard  so they have found  that beat  low dose or high dose alcohol is bad at  any cost  in lower dues of alcohol consumption  there is risk of cardiovascular disease  but the risk is mild  and obviously at higher level of alcohol  consumption the risk is higher  so moral of this story alcohol is bad at  any cost  that's one minute see you in next video